und zwar stelle ich mir die frage warum
ist eigentlich der präsident des robert
koch-instituts
lothar wieler noch im amt schauen wir
uns einfach mal die vergangenen
mittlerweile zwei monaten anfang
dezember da sagte lothar wieler voraus
in den nächsten wochen werden die
belegung auf den intensivstationen mit
komapatienten immer weiter ansteigen
deshalb müssen wir diesen knallharten
kurs verteidigen nur wenige tage später
erreichte die intensiv belegung ihren
höhepunkt seitdem fallen die zahlen
konstant erhält also wie trendumkehr der
del-tabelle komplett verpasst wenige
tage später da hatte der expertenrat
gerade seine stellungnahme abgegeben
auch mit gezeichnet von lothar wieler
und empfahl den politikern keine neuen
massnahmen zu verhängen denn will
erreichte das nicht am tag der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
veröffentlichte er sein eigenes papier
und forderte den ultimativen lockdown
damit überraschte er sogar karl
lauterbach und bundeskanzler olaf scholz
und jetzt der nächste große patzer den
haben wir vor zwei wochen gesehen die
eigenmächtige über nacht verkürzung des
genesenen status wissenschaftlich nicht
ansatzweise belegt von sechs monaten auf
drei monate dazu hat sich lothar wieler
zwei wochen lang nicht einmal erklärt
während hunderttausende bürger sich
fragen musste ob sie eigentlich noch ins
restaurant dürfen ob sie ohne test bus
und bahn fahren können ich würde sagen
das ist irgendwann die grenze erreicht
karl lauterbach gesundheitsminister ist
ja frisch im amt er muss auch nicht
jeder altlast mitschleppen deswegen
würde ich sagen danke lothar wieler
danke für ihre harte arbeit in dieser
pandemie sie haben sich wirklich
aufgeopfert für dieses land für die
pandemie bekämpfung auch wenn man ihm
nicht allem zustimmen muss hat er das
zweifellos getan aber irgendwann ist
auch mal gut an
[Musik]
der wenigen sie das einschätzen mit lila
na ja das ist natürlich immer sehr
leicht die menschen zu kritisieren die
da die entscheidungen fällen müssen wir
müssen sie in omikron ist ja plötzlich
aus dem nichts gekommen anfang dezember
und hat das ganze geschehen wieder
dynamisch beflügelt und wieder eine ganz
andere richtung gebracht die wir vorher
noch gar nicht auf dem radar hatten von
daher sind sicherlich fehler gemacht
worden sind auch ärgerlich da lagen wir
zum teil ja auch so wir persönlich
betroffen aber es ist ja auch das
phänomen wenn starke warnungen
ausgesprochen werden und alle ihr
verhalten anpassen dann tritt eben
dieses schlimmste szenario nicht ein das
heißt es nur win situation für die
wissenschaftler und eben auch in amerika
sehen wir das gleiche und ich glaube ist
es den sagen wir ratsamer vorsichtiger
zu sein etwas als zu leichtfertig damit
umzugehen weil ich bin ja für die
wirtschaft zuständig die schlimmste
variante was uns passieren könnte was
nicht ausgeschlossen ist okay
bestenfalls bekommen wir eine n de mi
das wäre fantastisch alles flacht
langsam ab aber es ist eben nicht
ausgeschlossen dass wir eine variante
bekommen die so ansteckend des wie
mikron aber so tödlich zum beispiel wie
saas also jedenfalls wesentlich
tödlicher was machen wir dann also ich
glaube dieser vorsichtiger kurs ist
schon ganz gut ich meine der vorwurf von
ihnen galt ist ja auch da hat uns alle
überrascht diese handstreichartig
verkürzung des genesenen status von
sechs auf drei monate das finde ich auch
völlig daneben kräftigen grundrechte ein
mann hat vielleicht von heute auf morgen
keine bewegung sind keine berufsfreiheit
mehr formal allerdings muss man
natürlich sagen war das korrekt
bundestag und bundesrat haben
gewissermaßen dem rkw carte blanche
gegeben jetzt gab es eine ausarbeitung
der wissenschaftlichen dienste dass die
das kritisiert haben aber wir exklusiv
veröffentlicht genau wie schön dass sie
sagen genau die hat doch noch mal bild
bild mit den vier buchstaben genau ich
dachte mir 1 4 auf jeden fall bundestag
und bundesrat haben das heft des
handelns demokratisch legitim formal
korrekt aus der hand gegeben haben
gewissermaßen gesagt es gilt das was in
der excel-tabelle beim rk ii steht wenn
er das wissen wollt schaut doch bitte
danach ist ruhe an einige zurück die fdp
sagt ja müsste der bundestag wieder
behandeln da kann ich nur sagen wie kann
so etwas geschehen wie kann ich so eine
wichtige entscheidung an der eingriffe
in die grundrechte hängen an eine
dynamische excel-tabelle des rk ii aus
delegieren das verstehe ich nicht
absolut ehrlich gesagt ich glaube die
waren einfach die haben nicht gewusst
was da kommen kann es ist natürlich
glücklich man wirklich verteidigte total
perplex als ich gesehen habe welche
vollmachten der bieler plötzlich hat
aber karl lauterbach hat der
ministerpräsident nun mal versprochen an
dem tag an dem das ja durchgesetzt wurde
ihr werdet alle rechtzeitig in form wird
ihr werdet benachrichtigt ihr könnt
einwände äußern wir diskutieren das mit
euch da wird nichts einfach so über
nacht passieren da kannte er offenbar
seinen lkw chef zu schlecht der hatte
auf einmal alles schon vorbereitet per
mausklick wurde der gewesenen status
damit die grundrechte von 100000
menschen zurückgesetzt er wird doch
warum sitzt ja nicht hier der wille auf
meinem platz zum beispiel und sie
stellen die fragen es würde mich
interessieren wie er reagiert so
wahnsinnig schwer von außen zu
beurteilen was ist jetzt da erklärbar
was mich da ich wünschte er würde hier
sitzen wir haben regelmäßig
interviewanfragen an herrn wieder
geschickt bislang nie mit positive
rückmeldung ich meine die frage die sie
gestellt haben wir warum noch im amt
laut aber ist natürlich da vorgesetzt
werden behördenleiter mir nicht ein
tierarzt auch herr bieler meiner böse
vermutung ist ja es ist gewissermaßen
die vorratshaltung eines sündenbocks
also wer weiß was da noch kommen mag und
dann kann man jemand jetzt schon mal ein
bisschen an die kandare nehmen und sagen
wir mal freundlichen das war dein
letzter fehlschuss jetzt ist ja ganz
ganz enge führung sozusagen und wenn
doch mal etwas passiert dann kann ich
sagen ja ich habe immer noch eine chance
gegeben und kann gewissermaßen die
sündenbock funktion bei herren wieder zu
einem womöglich noch dramatischeren
zeitpunkt abladen absolut ich glaube
dass es der einzige grund warum karl
lauterbach ihn nicht gehen lässt außer
beim genesenen status da hat es mich
gewundert dass er sich so vor ihn
gestellt hat also hat sich wirklich mit
der entscheidung gemein gemacht und hat
gesagt dass es wissenschaftlich
hervorragend begründet kommunikativ war
das vielleicht alles nicht so optimal
und dann kam ein wissenschaftler nach
dem anderen ich persönlich kann das ja
gar nicht beurteilen aber wenn carsten
wachsen will hendrik strikt kommen wenn
sogar sandra diese kommt hier eigentlich
nicht bekannteste für das sie äußerst
regierungskritisch ist sondern sie ist
ein regierungsberater und auch immer
gewesen und sagen das ist falsch gelesen
die sind genauso gut geschützt dann
stimmt ja nicht mal die
wissenschaftliche basis der arbeit des
robert koch instituts und
dann weiß ich überhaupt nicht worüber
wir sprechen das natürlich generell die
gefahr beim robert-koch-institut dass
man sich einen automatismus der
permanenten legitimation hinein gegeben
hat also man hat das gewissermaßen
gesagt das was regierungspolitik ist
beruht auf wissenschaftlicher expertise
und die wird gewissermaßen ausgegeben
oder zertifiziert vom
robert-koch-institut das sind unsere
leute das sind unsere leute man wird
also jetzt auch einen rückwirkenden
strich durch die bisherigen pandemie
politik ziehen sagen würde ja auf einmal
ist das nicht mehr so ganz
wissenschaftlich hoch exzellent was dass
apple hier anbietet also ich gerne
spannend finde um nochmal den punkt von
frau navidi einer aufzufangen und weiter
zu spinnen auch sie haben ja gesagt
vorsicht ist dann besser ich muss
ehrlich sagen ich bin es leid dass die
vorsicht walten gelassen wird wenn ich
die zahlen sehe der selbstmordraten bei
kindern die gestiegen ist wenn ich die
zahlen sehe und das muss man einfach
wirklich sagen wir haben einen sehr
hohen preis gezahlt in der pandemie und
den zahlen wir immer immer immer weiter
und ich muss wirklich sagen wenn wir
weiterhin immer wieder die vorsicht
first machen ich kann beispielsweise
meinen job ausüben ich bin nicht so
stark davon betroffen aber wenn man
beispielsweise auch in restaurants geht
die haben auch stark gelitten also wenn
man in die in die innenstädte geht da
sind auch viele läden die dicht machen
sehen wir eben gesagt sie sind ja auch
dafür die wirtschaft entsprechen über
die wirtschaft ich glaube dass vor allem
auch die vorsicht nehmen wir jetzt mal
die 2g plus regel nur als eine regel ja
vorsicht besser als nachsicht ist anders
könnte man sie ja nicht erklären die
außengastronomie beispielsweise ich kann
nur meine heimatstadt sprechen da wird
jetzt auch außengastronomie aufgebaut
und heizstrahler um es auch mal ein
bisschen ab zu viel einsatz den
umsatzverlust der letzten monate und
jahre
der darf nicht mal in der
außengastronomie draußen ein jemand
sitzen denn nur zwei impfungen hat und
nicht sein schnellstes an den tag mit
hut und ich finde es mittlerweile ist
man wirklich mal sagen muss das ist doch
reicht man kann oder verstehen sie alle
regelungen als bürgerin also mir geht es
wirklich langsam so ich habe einfach
keine lust mehr weil ich vieles nicht
mehr verstehe und ich auch viele ist als
eine sanierung auf fasse mittlerweile ja
das mag ja sein aber wenn sie sagen ich
bin es leid das ist eigentlich relativ
irrelevant weil es dem virus egal ist
denn wie roth des virus ist sie noch
nicht leid und es besteht eben große
gefahr und wenn wir nicht vorsichtig
sind dann werden die menschen sich
zurückziehen da sagen wir mal die
ansteckungsraten nehmen zu der staat
macht veranlasst keine maßnahmen dann
werden die leute trotzdem zu hause
bleiben sie werden nicht so viel
konsumieren sie werden eh nicht den
restaurants gehen von daher macht es
sinn kollektiv zu versuchen diese
krankheit in den griff zu bekommen sein
wir haben also als im gegensatz zu mir
immer noch die meinung in deutschland
dass jede einzelne maßnahme zur pandemie
bewältigung hilft nein ich sagte sein
dynamisches geschehen wir müssen unser
verhalten anpassen es werden stets
fehler geschehen wie eben der zettel von
dem lehrer da müssen wir darüber reden
und sollte ich bin mir sicher dass das
gerne zurück genommen wird und in
zukunft dann eben nicht mehr so gemacht
wird aber niemand ist ja für uns alle
neu und ja also ich glaube es besser
vorsichtig zu sein für die wirtschaft
tun sie das auch so harry me nach fast
zwei jahren pandemie also ich bin ein
bisschen anleihe in der ganzen sache
nicht wie herr piatosa experte und was
ich weiß ist ich habe mich impfen lassen
aus selbstschutz das ist mal der erste
gedanke gewesen und zwar inklusive
boostern ich bin einer freundin sehr
dankbar die das für mich ein bisschen
angestoßen hat und war froh dass ich
erst mal raus bin aus der kiste ich habe
nicht das gefühl dass diese impfung
jetzt einfach verhindert dass andere
angesteckt werden sondern so wie es im
augenblick aussieht kann ich mich auch
anstecken und mein gefühl wenn sie mir
ein bisschen kritik erlauben ist
kommunikativ war das ganze nicht erst
seit zwei monaten ein extremes desaster
aber auch politiker sind menschen es ist
eine pandemie wahrscheinlich so wenig
vorhersehbar
selbst wenn es planungsunterlagen gab
zehn jahre vorher schon wie man das
hätte machen müssen dass die leute zum
teil wirklich überfordert waren aber ja
da bin ich ganz bei ihnen ich hätte mir
gewünscht dass viele maßnahmen anders
kommuniziert werden offene die
unsicherheiten auch ehrlicher auf den
tisch gelegt werden ich will nicht
wissen bei der ersten impfung du bist
damit raus aus dem spiel und immer fit
und heiß plötzlich da jetzt brauchen wir
noch eine zweite und dritte und jetzt
schon klar ich brauch noch eine vierte
und fünfte brauche ich auch ich mache
das auch ich will mich selber schützen
das ist meine persönliche entscheidung
aber ich mache niemand anderem wirklich
niemand an seinem hof die leute sind
frei sich zu entscheiden wie sie mögen
so war es immer im land und wenn dann
hätte man eine impfpflicht sehr früh
machen müssen wir noch etwas machen kann
man darüber reden aber es ist so wie es
gelaufen ist ist es glaube ich kein
meisterstück gewesen aber es war auch
eine große herausforderung so ist das
ist so der reihe von der straße der ihr
mit spricht